china has sent off its only aircraft
carrier to take up position in the South
China Sea the location of a territorial
dispute with the Philippines officially
it's the vessels for a sea trial but the
timing says a lot on Saturday Beijing
unilaterally imposed an air defense zone
in disputed East China Sea territory
China's neighbors say it has no right
Beijing is domani that all airplanes fly
over the zone identify themselves to
Chinese authorities the east china sea
air defense identification zone is not
aimed at normal international flights
clear we hope that the relevant
countries airlines can proactively
cooperate so there is more order and
safety for flights already Japanese and
South Korean flights have defied the
order we have proposed that China's
declaration of its air defense zone on
the East China Sea be treated as an
emergency matter we have clearly
conveyed our government's regrets and
its demands that the situation be
rectified wood-eating we're but South
Korea's Defense Ministry says Beijing is
refusing to comply amid that disputes
the US aircraft carrier George
Washington is in the region for joint
military drills with Japan the u.s. has
already sent two b-52 bombers over the
defense zone without informing Beijing